et cédric ardue infectiologues au chu de
rennes et avec nos bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation d'abord je
voudrais vous entendre sur le variant
anglais ils représenteraient environ 1%
des tests positifs aux copies de 19
selon les résultats préliminaires d'une
enquête menée la semaine passée est ce
qu'il faut à s'inquiéter pas disons que
c'est toujours inquiétant d'avoir une
souche plus transmissible que les autres
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait une
surveillance des variants qui est qui
est assez active depuis le début
d'épidémie on al'avantage d'avoir un
virus qui ne mute pas énormément par
rapport à ce qu'on connaît pour d'autres
types de virus donc cette surveillance
elle nous permet de tracer effectivement
ces variants après effectivement
invariants qui se transmet à priori
entre on va dire 50% et peut-être même
100% plus facilement que la souche qui
circulait jusqu'à maintenant ça nous
incite à avoir renforcé au maximum tout
ce qui est mesures barrières masque
distanciation voilà puisque c'est la
seule chose qui est efficace quel que
soit le type de variants qui est qui et
qui circulent actuellement
alors la question c'est de savoir c'est
les mesures justement de restrictions
décidées par le gouvernement sont
suffisamment efficaces en fait ce qui se
passe par exemple au royaume uni où a
été celle à qui a été identifié ce
variant qui est très avancé sur le
territoire britannique a marre au
confinement nous on nous dit
effectivement qu'il ya pas besoin de
l'euro confinés dans se souvient que
l'année dernière par exemple pour
regarder l'italie et on disait la même
chose qu'il faut qu'on avait encore de
la marge
est ce que il faut craindre un scénario
identique à ce que connaît aujourd'hui
le royaume-uni 1
disons que le risque existe c'est à dire
que on a un risque de voir une
accélération épidémie tous nos chiffres
actuels de surveillance épidémique nous
montre qu'on est sur une phase
ascensionnelle donc
les mesures qu'il faut prendre pour
essayer de ne pas saturer le système de
santé
c'est des mesures qui sont qui sont
forcément contraignante donc
effectivement je pense que l'important
c'est d'avoir une observation très
rigoureuse de l'évolution de l'épidémie
et d'adapter nos mesures en fonction de
cette évolution
donc je pense qu'effectivement même si
un confinement est généralisée et pas à
l'ordre du jour là tout de suite c'est
quelque chose qui peut être revu la
semaine prochaine ou la semaine d'après
en fonction de l'évolution épidémique
donc ça veut dire qu'on pourrait vous se
diriger selon vous vinrent confinement
ah oui je pense qu'il faut rien exclure
en pratique depuis le début de
l'épidémie on navigue un peu à vue
malgré tout il faut dire que ce soit les
épidémiologistes les les médecins les
décideurs politiques
je verse et une situation fou voilà
c'est une situation à laquelle on s'est
habitué c'est à dire de prendre des
décisions en fonction des données du
moment et c'est pas quelque chose de
facile c'est un travail assez
considérable d'arriver à amener ces
décisions là mais voilà il faut toujours
se dire que la décision qu'on prend un
moment c'est une décision qu'il faut
pouvoir remettre en question la semaine
deux suivantes où la semaine d'après en
fonction de l'évolution épi des orvets
dit qu'on avait gardées à vue en tout
cas en ce concerne la stratégie
vaccinale olivier ferrand il l'a dit
hier lors de ses auditions devant les
parlementaires que la france ne naviguez
pas à vue on sait que cette campagne de
vaccination allait jugée trop lente les
effets ne vont certainement pas sa faute
à ressentir tout de suite en tout cas
auquel et vous votre position par
rapport à aux décisions qui ont été
prises jusqu'à présent en matière de
vaccination ya pas de caractère
péjoratif dans le dans le fait de
naviguer à vue je pense que c'est des
choses on est dans une
il faut pas croire que dans une épidémie
de ce type là avec un nouveau virus des
nouveaux variants un vaccin qu'on a
réussi à développer dans un temps
exceptionnellement court tout ça fait
que on peut pas programmer les choses
comme on peut le faire dans d'autres
pathologies avec avec plusieurs mois
d'avancé tant que le fait de naviguer
vu c'est pour moi finalement le fait de
se mettre dans une situation on a cette
capacité d'adaptation permanente aux
évolutions épidémique pour le vaccin je
pense que c'est une situation qui est un
peu spécifique à la france
là il ya une voie là il ya une
hésitation vaccinale en france qui est
assez importante et je pense que voilà
il y avait des inquiétudes qu'ils
étaient légitimes par rapport au fait de
savoir de com pour comment on avait pu
développer un vaccin aussi rapidement
est ce qu'on connaissait bien les effets
secondaires
donc il ya eu une stratégie initiale 4
consistait à essayer d'être assez
progressif voilà je pense que ça peut ça
peut se défendre
ce qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui c'est que
on est dans la capacité de faire plus et
qu'on essaye d'augmenter notre puissance
en termes de vaccination au cours du
mois de janvier au cours du mois de
février d'aller plus vite finalement que
ce qui était prévu de de ce qui avait
été prévu initialement
donc ces voix là c'est pareil c'est un
peu une capacité d'adaptation en
pratique le couvre-feu généralisée qui
pourrait être décidée on verra demain en
fonction des annonces de jean castex
lors de son point-presse à un couvre-feu
de généraliser avancé à 18 heures sur le
territoire à ce que cela peut vous
sembler efficace disons que toutes les
mesures qui sont prises en termes de
limitation des contacts sociaux ont une
certaine efficacité mais là aussi c'est
on a du mal à juger par exemple quel va
être le le point d'impact en termes
épidémique d'une avancée du couvre-feu
de deux heures on pense qu'elle est
telle qu'elle existe mais aujourd'hui on
n'a pas vraiment les outils pour dire
exactement on a des modèles et ses
modèles on sait que de temps en temps
ils peuvent être prises en défaut et
donc on n'a pas vraiment les outils qui
nous permettent de dire finalement de
combien on va pouvoir ralentir
l'épidémie en faisant un couvre-feu qui
durera qui sera 2h plus précoce que ce
qu'il est actuellement
donc on ne peut pas mesurer finalement
l'impact de cette mesure
c'est à dire on va pas le mesurer à
priori quand le premier couvre-feu a été
mis en place
on avait assez peu de données des pays
étrangers on avait quelques données sur
la guyane en france puisque c'est une
mesure qui avait été instauré en guyane
depuis un certain temps et qui avait
montré qu'on avait un certain impact sur
le l'évolution de l'épidémie
mais bon les conditions climatiques en
guyane les conditions sociales sont
quand même très différente de la
métropole donc c'était difficile
d'extrapoler et on avait assez peu de
données sur les autres sur les autres
pays donc on a montré à posteriori que
c'était très efficace puisque on a
vraiment eu un ralentissement épidémique
important mais a priori on ne savait pas
très bien quelle est elle qu elle et
qu'elle allait être le l'importance de
l'impact sur le sur l'évolution
épidémique merci beaucoup à vous cédric
a review je rappelle que vous êtes
infectiologues au chu de rennes